uh saints buccaneers game from sunday
night a stunning outcome
no one saw 38-3 coming no way in hell
and i'm telling you all these saints
fans that want to troll us for picking
the bucks did you bet your mortgage on
the saints winning did you bet your
mortgage on the saints cover hey you
know what i did pick the saints to cover
i went back and looked at our picks from
last week so i'm not completely
at fault here i did think they'd cover i
didn't think they'd win but i did think
they'd cover i thought it was gonna be a
three-point game it wasn't it was a
35-point game the other way bruce
aaron's as his
uh
as his efforts usually do speaking to
reporters and being very candid although
he was a little more nuanced than usual
it's unmistakable who he thinks was
responsible for the loss on sunday night
here's erin's from yesterday
the interception to a b
that was just a poor throw
the one to chris chris read to write
properly tom thought he was going deep
he stopped uh those things can happen
sometimes when you're when you're doing
it on the run mike was open
a bunch in that ball game he just didn't
he didn't get targeted that's all he was
open
mike was was open
the rest of the time he made tom a
couple of good throws he made some
really good catches
uh the first third down we should have
went to him
decided to go to gronk but uh
yeah i think he he played more than i
wanted him to because of the situation
of the game but uh
first first ball game he did he did fine
that last comment obviously about
antonio brown's playing time mike is
mike evans chris is chris godwin
when you listen to those statements all
kind of mashed together because that
wasn't all one continuous flow it was
different answers to different questions
but when you look at all of it
he's got issues with the accuracy of tom
brady on sunday night a poor throw on
the ball that was thrown to antonio
brown it looked like brown quit on the
route right accidentally not on purpose
either way it was going to work either
way
throw the safety
you know either if antonio brown runs
the route
he's throwing the ball too short and two
inside the safety was there to make the
play all along so what whether they
weren't on the same page bruce aaron
just going wait he still threw the ball
it was a bad throw and he just doesn't
want to hear you know the oh what if
what if he did this and all that sorry i
didn't mean to interrupt you man no
that's all right and all these comments
about mike evans was open he was open
you saw her inspire he was open we just
didn't throw it to him well who's making
the decisions about where to throw it
and to whom right to throw it
that is the quarterback so
there's not just an accuracy problem
they cropped up on sunday night there's
a decision-making problem if evans is
repeatedly open
and the ball doesn't get thrown to him
what's going on here and then antonio
brown is open on the first third down
they were facing that that game which
would have avoided the three and out
which may have helped stop the bleeding
that would have kept it from becoming 28
nothing and then 31 nothing uh
you throw it to the guy who isn't open
so
you know it's not as blatant as it was
after the first loss to the saints when
bruce arians
just came out and said
you know tom made mistakes tom did this
tom did it's still there it's
unmistakable it's not something that
ever happened with tom brady when he was
in new england for 20 years and uh you
know back in week one
my
my comment was gee how's tom gonna react
week nine after what we saw sunday night
i don't think i care and i don't think
aryan should care because tom did stink
on sunday night period well yeah it
wasn't a great game by tom certainly i
mean but i don't sit there and just
blame it on tom i didn't look at the
game back yesterday and just go oh my
gosh mike evans is so wide open how dare
they it was just egregious how well he
played i mean listen they got their
butts kit their offensive line got their
butts kit you know bruce arians and the
coaching staff did nothing to establish
the running game or run the ball at all
and i would argue the best thing about
the tampa bay buccaneers and tom brady
this year has been their ability to get
in some tight end sets and play action
and take deep shots down the field or
because those tight ends are in there
max protect take deep shots down the
field they didn't do that they lined up
and like it was like oh no we got
antonio brown you can't match up with us
screw you we're going to throw it every
play listen i watched that game closely
you know there's some plays there was a
second and 20 maybe in the second drive
of the game where yeah brady i wish
you'd hang in there and throw the in cut
to mike evans there was a third and
three you know when they were down 21-0
i believe at that point where he's
running up the middle of the field it's
not like the most perfect look in the
world you know me i call it how it is if
i thought he was open and brady was
being a wimp and not throwing it i'd go
man brady was being a wimp he didn't
throw it but it was tight so
you know i don't know so why so why is
aaron saying well i is bruce
let me ask my questions yeah yeah but
let me ask you the question
if if you're watching the film and
you're concluding that evans isn't
running around you know waving his arms
wide open like jimmy or in super bowl
three when oral moral didn't see him on
the front flicker right right um i'm
glad you remember that just passed not
that long ago by the way um but but yeah
but if if that's not the case then what
the hell is bruce doing is this at a
deeper level
is this the residual impact of the a b
power play because as you were saying
you put the tight ends out there you run
the ball that helps kick start the
offense you get into play action you
start moving the ball down the field you
score some points you have some longer
drives you don't go three and out now
they got a b so they got to go three
receiver sets to get a b on the field
because tommy wants a b on the field
tommy wants his buddy out there tommy
wants his reclamation project on the
field and you see what happens i wonder
if this is just
a sign
of a deeper
tug of war between aryans who didn't
want antonio brown let's not forget that
he did not want antonio brown
is this a deeper back and forth between
the two of them maybe it is well i i
think it's i i don't know if i'm ready
to go there yet but either way i think
what he's he wants more from tom i do
think that i think he still like fights
the hey i want you to be a little bit
more aggressive you know i want you just
to ha you know instead of like
there was
hey there's another play you know i
think the game's at 28 nothing that
because i when he's when i saw these
quotes yesterday i just gotten done
watching the game not long before that
and i went back and i just went you know
let me just give one more real good look
to mike evans and things like that yeah
i mean i think that's what he he's
saying one he's trying to stick up for
going like hey let's not blame mike
evans he's open and he's healthy and
things are good and it wasn't like it
was egregious like i said but i think
the other thing too is sometimes with
brady he's just wanting to continue to
push him to be a little more aggressive
hey hang in the pocket for you know a
tenth of a second more and instead of
that five yard completion we're gonna
get the 20 yard completion i think
that's what frustrates him we know that
that's bruce's mo and you know i think
there's probably a handful of plays
where again i'm not going to be overly
critical because it wasn't like there
was great pass pro all night he's trying
to manage the football game and not let
bad things happen because they're in the
hole early on and things like that
and you know that led to him wanting to
get the bot of his hands but i think
ultimately that's what bruce is worried
about he's going hey wait i know i had a
concept over here and that's cool and
you got a four yard completion but on
the back side we had mike evans you know
running an 18-yard in cut against cover
two and that's exactly what we want and
we need you to throw that laser in there
to do that and i think he's still
kind of got that poker next to brady's
butt that way because he's still trying
to get it out of them all the time to be
aggressive that way
here's where i can confuse them yeah why
doesn't aryan say what you said
why doesn't aryan say that instead of
painting this picture of mike evans
running around like jimmy or in super
bowl three i don't know either i mean
because bruce seems to let his emotions
get the best of them at times i don't
know and i you know it didn't do what's
like what you this was monday this
wasn't right after the game i know but
it's like i feel like you're probably
watching
and he's frustrated and it's just it's
all boiling over and mike i'll say the
one thing to you too
you know yeah antonio brown's there
but
man i i don't know i mean does tampa
feel the pressure a little bit i mean
everybody expects them to be a major
player here that was a big time loss
it's two kind of ugly games in a row now
they're six and three you know i think
he is feeling the pressure to a degree
to where
yeah he understands the expectations how
everybody perceives them to be this year
and i think that game probably scared
the hell out of them with the way they
looked because it's the worst they
looked it's the worst they executed and
at the bottom line they were physically
whooped they got their butts whooped up
front and that's probably going to scare
them more than anything
yeah i mean here's the thing you got to
worry about your game behind the saints
in the lost column they hold the
tiebreaker and
right now three losses gets you the
seventh seed yeah in the nfc so they
they don't have much margin for error
they're going to be on the outside
looking in and if they fail to get to
the playoffs that is
absolutely a failure of tom brady's
first act with a team definitely you
know at the end of the day it could be
both the patriots and the buccaneers
don't make it to the playoffs uh this
year what else stood out when you took a
look at uh at the game yesterday well i
mean i you know that that the the one
thing on that offensive side of the ball
like i said they never established the
run do anything like that they had no
chance and then i think the biggest
thing that jumps outside or out to me
you know on the other side of the ball
with the saints first off i mean the
bucks were so bad on offense they
couldn't get out of their own end so the
saints had great field position all game
long but you know there was a
a tempo to the saints offense and an
attack mode right away and it might not
have just been with the run game but it
was you know
when you watch it back they got up to
the line of scrimmage quick it was
huddled get up the line of scrimmage
they snapped the ball with like 28
seconds it was an array of personnels
and motions and everything like that and
i think what jumped out to me more than
anything mike was
the way tampa played on defense just the
style in which they played not
aggressive not in your face kind of like
ben don't break style of defense and
that to me
throughout the drew brees career with
sean payton is just a deadly way to die
slow because they're just going to pick
you apart like they did at no point
would they ever stop you know tampa's
got some studs i'm shocked they didn't
let devin white go man-to-man and camaro
a little bit and carlton davis and and
jamel dean match up against receivers
they're pretty damn good cover corners
uh
that that i think you know the mission
the game plan and just the way the
saints executed on a defense that i felt
played soft all night i think would be
the next big thing that jumped out to me
michael thomas your your impression of
his impact and his return after missing
eight total weeks with that ankle and
then hamstring looked good he did i you
know i mean it looked like he was
running full go you know not a ton of
balls came his way you know this is
where like
him being out could really end up being
a great gift for this offense because
it's forced them to find other ways to
get guys the ball instead of like hey
let's throw to michael thomas 15 times a
game all the time you know i think now
it may lead itself to he gets some more
favorable matchups because the ball is
going somewhere else and now you see a
few more big plays out of him in the
pass game but you know physically look
good but i think that was what i was so
impressed with you know
like the bucks
they got a really good run stopping
defensive line
and i think sean payton said you know
what i'm not going to get in a phone
booth fight with this group
i'm just gonna spread them out
i don't think their scheme can match up
with this and he kind of tore it apart
all night long
and you know drew brees had that
shoulder injury
um
and he showed no signs of it and and uh
even in the wind was able to perform at
a very high level here's the spray chart
for drew brees from
sunday night's game look you know not a
lot down the field okay yeah the one to
the right there but most of it is just
typically where drew brees throws it but
a lot of green dots not many white dots
he was very very efficient as he always
is and when you have all those pieces
working and breeze and peyton connecting
and taysom hill
having his best game of the season on
top of everything else this is a deadly
team
and it's funny how our perception
changes every week about who the best
teams are especially in the nfc
right now
yeah it's hard not to start in the nfc
subject to change after the next set of
games i would say the saints are well
we're trying to project that's what we
do i mean you know we yeah we're not
like you know uh
crystal ball and can tell the future
every time hey the bucks were doing some
things that yeah were intriguing to me
you know the saints have had some off
moments as we've talked about you know
we knew we talked about them being one
of those teams that has the potential to
be the most complete team in the nfc we
just hadn't seen it this year we saw it
in this one definitely i mean across the
board defense probably played its best
game of the year and you know the taste
some hill part of that offense to me
they would be crazy not to continue to
have him on the field and have a package
of plays every week yeah drew brees in
rhythm he'll surgically pick you apart
oh wait now we need a big play
or something different the taysom hill
offense
really sets up because it puts the
defenses in a big time bind you worry
about getting outnumbered in the run
game then it becomes these great pass
looks to where it's like wow this is a
beginner's level defense because they're
so worried about being outnumbered and
him running that he gets to throw the
ball like the first crosser the first
completion he had of the game where drew
brees would be drooling if he saw a
defense play that coverage against him
he'd be like oh man i'm gonna throw a
touchdown every play tonight but
it is another creative way to give them
a schematical advantage for an offense
that doesn't have necessarily big pipe
type guys i think they got to continue
to go to that well i really do i think
it's one of the great advantages they
have on their offense
did you notice on sunday night and look
it's possible they've done this before
when taysom hill is under center but
drew brees was split wide and instead of
just kind of taking a step back and not
engaging the defensive back which is
always a smart thing to do if you're a
starting quarterback out there spread
wide he took a few steps back
aggressively now look it was part of an
effort to fool the defense but it's
almost like they're they're setting up
for future defenses to follow away the
possibility of hill throwing a lateral
out to breeze and having breeze throw a
forward pass from that posture out there
which would be awesome if they ever do
it that's it there was one moment there
was one moment where they were selling
the possibility of it and drew did a
nice job he went back you know a good
five yards and was you know throw it
here throw it here but uh if they ever
pull that one off then uh that'll be a
play
all right i would think that would come
mike i really do i mean again and you
know that play you're talking about
taste of milk pumped it to drew brees
right as he was starting to scramble
and it gave him a little advantage and
more of a window to open up and he ended
up getting what a 15 20 yard run on it
uh but that's what i mean
they're going to be able to do different
things yeah drew brees isn't going to
throw 60-yard bombs or 50-yard bombs but
you have that part of the offense they
might be able to create 40 and 50-yard
plays because of the schematical
advantages taysom hill gives you when he
does get that quarterback yeah look it's
easy to look at taysom hill and look at
his numbers from early in the year and
oh it's a this is stupid why are you
promoting this guy why are you hyping
this guy because he's got the potential
to be really damn good and we saw it
last year in the playoffs and we got a
glimpse of it finally on sunday night he
had had other moments this year but
sunday night was when we really started
to see that triple threat catching
running throwing that he can be which
complicates the effort to try to slow
down the saints offense
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports